how much did how much did the website
cost you I think it was 370 something
370 dollars thousand what the was
it someone just domain squatting yeah
you just talk it down what was the
original price no I just came into
asking they were in talks for somebody
else and they made a negotiator I am but
what's the goal you know what I mean for
me the cost of negotiating it because
you had another buyer that they had been
haggling with and so I figured that the
seller was kind of tired of haggling
with this other guy I think the number
that they were at was like 325 or
something like that and they were trying
to create some sort of payment plan and
I was like I'll pay 370 today cash I can
wear it tomorrow and so the deal closed
in like two days and they had been in
talks for like two months for me it's
like is there actually a difference in
how much value I'm gonna get out of
something if I pay 50 000 less or the
downside risk of me just not getting it
for me is significantly higher